[Musik]
dieser Moment diese Unterschrift wurde
zum Trauma der Ukraine
1994 gepräsident kutschmar die
ukrainischen Atomwaffen ab an Russland
in dem Glauben dass Sicherheitsgarantien
etwas wert sind
im Gegenzug garantieren die USA Russland
sowie Großbritannien der Ukraine die
Selbstständigkeit und verpflichten sich
das Land weder anzugreifen noch mit
wirtschaftlichen Zwangsmaßnahmen unter
Druck zu setzen weil eine
Sicherheitsgarantie gegeben von Russland
ganz offenkundig untauglich ja
gefährlich ist suchen die Unterstützer
der Ukraine nach einer verlässlichen
Gewehr das Russland nicht noch einmal
angreift und das finden selbst die
richtig die für das Ende jeder
Militärhilfe sind aber im Gegenzug muss
die Ukraine Garantien dafür bekommen
dass es nicht noch mal zu einem solchen
Angriffskrieg kommt Russland ist eine
Weltmacht und Atommacht und die Ukraine
ist ein ganz ganz kleines Land und sonst
wären die wirklichen Gefahren ja wie
bekommt man die Ukraine außer Gefahr wer
garantiert und wie lange Präsident
selenski wäre die naheliegendste Lösung
am liebsten die Lösung Teil einer
bereits funktionierenden
Sicherheitsgarantie zu werden der NATO
einen stärkeren Schutz als durch 23
Staaten darunter die USA gibt es nicht
vor allem die Osteuropäer geben selensky
recht
jeder hat gesagt dass die Ukraine für
die europäische Sicherheit kämpft wenn
das stimmt muss sie auch Teil der
europäischen Sicherheit werden
aber mit kurz und mittelfristigem Schutz
durch Aufnahme in die NATO rechnet
selbst die Ukraine nicht in den
Gesprächen die seit Kriegsbeginn hinter
den Kulissen geführt werden will etwa
Deutschland nicht einmal darüber reden
und daher gilt was die NATO immer
deutlich gemacht hat die Politik der
offenen Tür und zugleich ist auch klar
dass wir mitten in einem Krieg nicht
über eine neuere Mitgliedschaft sprechen
können wenn nicht die NATO wer soll dem
überfallenen Land eine
Sicherheitsgarantie erteilen welche
Staaten wären bereit wären stark genug
und glaubwürdig genug um sich als
Schutzmächte zu verpflichten
es muss die USA darin sein es muss
möglichst China drin sein und Russland
muss das sozusagen mit seiner
Unterschrift
sozusagen festschreiben die Sicherheit
der Ukraine ein weiteres Mal mit in die
Hände Russlands legen die Ukraine lehnt
das ab und vertraut lieber den
westlichen Staaten
ich denke schon dass Deutschland dazu
gehören kann ich denke dass die USA
selbstverständlich dazu gehören werden
aber ich glaube das ist eine bessere
Struktur die sicherer ist aber das hieße
das deutsche Soldaten im Zweifel für die
Ukraine sterben müssten wenn man eine
solche Garantie abgibt dann muss das so
gelten es gibt nicht viele Politiker die
bereit sind der Ukraine Soldaten zu
schicken wenn schon das schicken von
Waffen und populär und heftig umkämpft
ist dabei gilt das als die am ehesten
durchsetzbare Sicherheitsgarantie der
Ukraine dauerhaft so viele und so starke
Waffen liefern dass sie sich selbst
schützen kann
überraschende Zustimmung dazu aus einer
Partei die Waffenlieferungen eigentlich
grundsätzlich ablehnt
wir haben aber jetzt eine Situation dass
man der Ukraine ja nicht sagen kann gibt
alle Waffen ab dann ist die Ukraine am
Ende und deswegen bin ich der festen
Überzeugung dass wir hier Übergänge
brauchen das wäre fatal also schon jetzt
ist die kleine Ukraine das
hochgerüchteste Land
in Europa und sehr unerfahren eigentlich
ist die Ukraine das größte Land Europas
und eigentlich unfreiwillig erfahren
inzwischen aber es ist nicht nur ein
ganz grundsätzlicher Streit wie man
Frieden schafft sondern auch wie man ihn
eines Tages schützt